and get to be a crowded Independence Day
at Lake Mead yeah the water a great
place to escape to beat the heat but
you're sharing the water with others who
are not always very responsible eight
news now reporter Victoria Saha was
there today on what you need to know to
stay safe
as you can see many people are already
making their way towards their boats
here at Lake Mead with the holiday
weekend and triple digit temperatures
colliding it's going to be a pretty busy
few days here out in the water so
authorities say they're doing everything
they can to make sure everyone stays
safe
the sun beaming down on you and Breeze
in your hair sounds like the perfect way
to spend your holiday out on the water
we spent Saturday night and Sunday night
out on the water we found Kieran Cox
cleaning out his boat before taking it
out again as a veteran boater he knows
how important it is to share the water
safely to keep your distance from other
people if you don't know them you know
and just uh go slow the lake and beaches
are expected to be crowded it can be a
real problem and it's very hazardous
especially when you have a lot of people
out there John Haynes with Lake Mead
National Recreation Area says although
it's been a calm weekend so far there's
already been a few boaters pulled over
for driving Under the Influence here is
how you could spot one they're loud
they're obnoxious they're not driving
safely they're creating wakes and no
wake zones Haynes is hopeful everyone
will prioritize their own safety as
they've already had a tragic start to
the summer Father's Day weekend six
people died two of them were drownings
we do have extra staff out all weekend
long to try to keep people safe safety
it's always a priority for the Daniels
family making sure we have a designated
driver and make sure we have plenty of
ice life vests another part of keeping
safe is listening to your body if you're
a passenger on a boat and you've enjoyed
a couple of adult beverages remember to
take a break and drink some water so
your body doesn't dehydrate reporting
from Lake Mead Victoria Saha 8 News Now
and for those who are looking to spend
the fourth at the lake please keep in
mind no fireworks are allowed on
National Recreation areas and that also
includes those little sparklers